versailles versailles qui resplendit ça
y est après huit ans de travaux les
appartements sont enfin restauré
inauguré ce soir par françois léotard le
ministre de la culture les travaux
commencés en soixante dix huit dont on
compte ainsi restaurer tout le
rez-de-chaussée les appartements mais
aussi le musée de l'histoire de france
un événement considérable pour tous les
visiteurs du château ils sont nombreux
bien sûr nous en parlerons avec pierre
lemoine conservateur en chef de
versailles pierre jean petit et tout de
suite nous fait visiter les nouveaux
appartements
il y avait les matériaux des boiseries
splendide authentique qui dormaient dans
les réserves depuis le xviiie siècle
comme on voit il en reste encore
il y avait les plans avant de casser les
murs pour son musée d'histoire
l'architecte frédéric neveu avait fait
relevé jusque dans les moindres détails
les appartements qu'on donne un souvenir
pour louis-philippe sans ses dessins
rien n'aurait été possible
il y avait aussi le savoir-faire d'une
poignée d'artisans successeur talentueux
de ceux qui ont construit et décorer le
château
il y avait enfin quelques meubles
d'origine acheté par l'état ou
généreusement offerts par des
particuliers barbara houston la duchesse
de windsor
il y avait donc tout ce qu'il fallait
pour faire renaître après sept ans de
travaux les fameux appartement du
rez-de-chaussée où vécurent le dauphin
la dauphine et mesdames fille de oui car
avec ces précieux petits cabinets de
derrière qui servait de refuge à
l'intimité des princes
le résultat le voici
éblouissant
à la place du musée triste et
poussiéreux de plain pied avec les
fleurs les jets d'eau fraîche lumineuse
souriante 38 salles reconstitué à
l'identique les boudoirs les
bibliothèques les petits salons les
cabinets travail où le dauphin s'ennuyer
avec la dauphine ou mademoiselle
victoire et mademoiselle adélaïde se
gaver de gâteaux et de chocolat avant
d'aller taper sur le clavecin
mieux que les appartements d'apparat et
les salons officiels il évoque la maison
royale le versailles habité celui de la
vie quotidienne tout aussi luxueux que
l'autre mais avec en plus une petite
touche de confort bourgeois qui nous le
rend plus sensible
entre les nouveaux appartements sous la
galerie des glaces la galerie basse elle
aussi resterait débarrasser de ses
cloisons louis philippe
plus étonnant encore l'escalier de
gabriel l'architecte du roi
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'existait que
sur le papier à l'état de plans marie
antoinette avait fait interrompre les
travaux pour dresser un théâtre dans la
cage
la république terminant l'ouvragé roi
jusqu'où peut mener le goût de la
restauration